[Music]
I am with the great Lauren Cohen here
Lauren I have to ask you had this
amazing monologue in the final season of
Walking Dead about not forgiving Negan
yet when you talk to him but with Lauren
herself at this point where the dead
city is Forgiven Negan would I forgive
someone in this way I would actually
really really like to believe but I
don't have the levels of trauma that
that person has
and
but I inherently in my heart believe
that the end goal is always to find it
yeah yeah I hope we hopefully stay with
Maggie soon it's so exciting everyone
check out dead City and Lauren Kelly
apprecia thank you so much okay
everybody I am so excited today because
I am joined by Gaius Charles who plays
Perler Armstrong Marshall going after
Negan how you doing man I'm good man how
are you good I'm so excited for people
to see the show you're such a great
character and a great actor now was it
intimidating though having to be a
character that chases after an iconic
character like Negan yeah well low-key
I'll tell you this so when I got the
role I started watching the show so I
watched like the first three or four
seasons just like binge like oh I gotta
like get into this world I gotta you
know look at you know what's what the
story is and what the show is and then I
jumped ahead so like I fell in love with
all characters like everybody like all
the ogs are like those are my people
right and then I jump ahead to season
seven
and it's still Negan I'm like this dude
is threatening all my people and then he
takes out Glenn I was like
now when he took out Glenn it was like I
you know I talked to so many people so
many fans and that was like a A Moment
Like That was a moment where like
everybody just was like whoa you know so
for my character to come in and now you
know seek to bring him to Justice was
really cool because I'm chasing him I
know some of the things he's done and
you know being from new Babylon our
whole Law and Order culture it's just
kind of cool to tap in there because I
think that's still a sensitive spot for
the fans yeah that's really interesting
and it's interesting too because people
are going to see in the show that your
character is on the chase for Negan like
you're saying but that he also has a lot
of alone time on screen is that
challenging as an actor sometimes just
like okay I'm I'm holding this scene
down yeah no I mean that was cool I had
a lot of scenes with uh Gelco who plays
um
well I can't really say all the things
he does but he plays somebody that is a
very bad dude
um and so yeah you know I had scenes
with him and I've always like low-key
like personally I've been a super fan of
Gelco as an act like as a stage actor
like I saw him in pillow man and like
all this type of stuff so you know he
plays the crow at and I remember the
first day I met him we were doing a
scene I think it was episode two and you
know like I'm pulling a gun on him and
he kicks the gun out of my hand and
we're rehearsing and everything and then
I'm looking at him and I'm like
pillow man pillow man
I'm like yo Joker and he's like okay
yeah yeah so it was just really cool
working with him working with uh Jeffrey
just everybody you know whether we're
doing like these group scenes or whether
you're doing these solo scenes it was
just great to tap into and have fun with
yeah I love your energy and excitement
for this project and fans of this big
universe are gonna love to see that
um what would you say to those fans what
do you think they're like most about
your character
I think uh I think the fans are really
gonna like seeing somebody be about
their business or like they're gonna
like seeing somebody trying to rebuild
this world I think um you know we've
seen a lot of iterations of The Walking
Dead a lot of different but I think our
at least you know from my perspective
you know we're really trying to get back
to a sense of normalcy as much as we can
and I know we've seen versions of that
but um I think the fans are going to
enjoy seeing just that Law and Order
come back that you know attempt to try
to re-establish Society in a certain way
that we can identify with now and then
you know some of the challenge and
challenges and issues and setbacks that
come because of that it's a great answer
everyone I can't tell how great this
show is you're gonna love it and you're
gonna love guys in it guys thank you so
much for joining me today and talk to
you in the future thank you thank